you got the inspiration to make a rock
album did everyone say to you don't do
it Dolly like uh stay in your lane or
they don't talk to you like that no not
anymore at my age I don't really you
know have to think too much about what I
can and can't do but I think now I have
such a fan base that I've built Through
The Years with the movies and all the
different things that I've done that I
think they're just more curious about
what I'm going to do next so when I
decided to do I thought well I got to
earn my keep if I'm going to be in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame I got to have
a rock album I should mention you do
Wrecking Ball with your goddaughter
Miley Cyrus I I've never had a
goddaughter but if I if I had a
goddaughter like Miley Cyrus that'd be
very cool I mean uh you know is very
cool I love I love Miley she's a she's
my little sweetheart I've known her
since before she was born actually well
she smart enough to take advantage of
the fact that you're her godmother and
would she come to you for career advice
well she's asked me a lot of things and
she mostly just runs things by me and we
talk I she's very successful Molly's
very smart she's very uh she's very
intuitive about the business and I I
just think Molly is a a spectacular
human being and an amazing talent so how
did you end up being her but but when
you're the goddaughter were you that
close with Billy Ray and and the and yes
that's how it happened I when Billy had
the big song uh Achy Breaky Heart well
we toured together I was on tour and
then really U toured with me and so uh
that's how we just got to be good
friends cuz he's a Kentucky boy I'm from
Tennessee and he said you got to be my
daughter you know we're having a girl
and you got to be her uh godmother I
said well I'd be honored so actually
Molly and I took over from there we've
just stayed very very close Through The
Years you know most people I know have
God children by the way your voices
blend beautifully
[Music]
here that gives me the goose you love
that song I love that song she did it on
the show live I I I I think she's
fantastic oh she's amazing she did a uh
a she played with Metallica on my show
Believe It or Not so you know really
yeah yeah she kind of picked that up
from you like uh there's no genre that
she won't touch you know what I mean no
when she's capable of any of it she's
got a fantastic voice I just felt
honored I love that song and I love
Molly and when I started to choose all
these people for my record or songs that
I wanted to do I thought I have to have
Molly